jail Spooner I am ridiculously pleased
to have you say yeah how long are we
trying to put you down for many years
many years so we have the most insane
story ever because you were what I was
at a crash course you want first have a
student I know that's just a madness
people people cuz do you know what
people use decide to me some who is your
first ever student who's your first ever
student and I was like I looked into it
and it was you and of course I
remembered you you're my first student
and tried to track you down to see how
you were doing text you text you again
then thought forget this I'm gonna phone
er phones you and it was like ding ding
ding number anymore and then I just gave
up until a few weeks ago when you
messaged me and said Sam welcome why
would you tell me what did you say well
I was in South Africa and I literally
was like watching all of your videos and
I was like let me just message him this
is after I went back onto the crash
course Ken
yes and I messaged you and I was like I
challenge you to yeah yeah do something
and yeah woke up in the morning and I
didn't hear anything and I was like okay
no worries I'm still coming to the
Academy so it's all good yeah and I just
got a message from you saying hey when
he free stalking us like right now and
yeah you told me then and there that I
was the first ever person to be yet no
she didn't how that me feel I honestly
elated yeah honesty you had no idea
you're my first student none and then I
asked you to come out for dinner
mm-hmm and we had a dinner and I made
some spice yes you did which burn my
mouth
but here's the crazy thing I'm so when I
spoke I was so glad that you've actually
been successful and I know in your mind
you might think I'm not that successful
but to be fair you are successful in
property and I know you've got whole new
heights to get to and that's why you're
just join the Academy and when you came
to the crash course we weren't even
running the Academy yeah this was like
and I'm back in the back in the bunion
the back in the night well yeah oh god
that was 2014 2014 first ever crash
course in November so what you done
since going on the crash course you my
first student impress us tell us what
you've done well
the first thing I done was I put my
council house I bought that a few years
ago right to buy right to buy right to
acquire I bought that because I was
inspired by your story and what you
taught me and then I went on to
commercial property which is something I
was always into so I have a late-night
bar called Tunnel London and it's an
afro be is that the best Afrobeat club
in the venue in the UK so we I wish no
no that the tunnel far I would say it's
about about a million a year a million
the year with an episode profit of
fifteen percent you said mmm that's good
yeah that's awesome that's like more
than most people's salary yeah by and by
a long way yeah what else and I got a
rent to rent as well how much is that
man that one brings me a thousand pounds
a month and where is that cancer stuff
came just a London you know what though
I'm so glad that you've been successful
because it's my very first student and
as I say I know you've got way way more
hype yeah but I rent to rent making a
thousand pounds a month you've got a
beautiful little boy here we might hear
in the back lub I can't take credit for
that because I don't teach people how to
set up a club but actually you've got
some kind of inspiration absolutely but
I mean but you did raise finance for
that I did yeah how much fun so we had
to raise two hundred and fifty thousand
your partner
absolutely so we vigorously went but
because you'd had introduced me to the
world of property I was able to I knew
you actually introduced me to networking
as well as circle so that built a lot of
confidence and that enabled me to be
able to be bold enough to go out and
raise funds all of that a story you know
what though when you messaged me the
hairs on my neck stood up I got shivers
down my arm honestly I don't know that
sounds crazy but because he was just
like this person that I met six years
ago who was my first student who I've
watched I watched your video testimonial
from the crash course yeah with you
crazy yeah I know I just feel like you
know for all the places that I've gone
to and
everything I've read about property I
actually know how to do actually you
know how to look and find my my own
deals and I've just had a real over in
all the gaps have been filled and that's
how I feel more confident and more
comfortable with the business and with
the yeah really excited about it but but
seeing what you've done and I know I've
only been a small part you know but okay
I may be no I mean to introduce someone
to their career and their dreams I think
that's a big policy IQ booth but you
know what though I mean you've worked so
hard over the last six years you should
be so so proud of what you've done and
and you got the Academy you got on stage
and I gave the most it was like you were
a born speaker you know you gave the
most powerful message to that didn't I
said you know I'm gonna I'm gonna be
coming on stage whether you read this
message or not
I'll show you one day that I'm actually
gonna speaking on stage and that
manifested itself really weak within a
week you're on stage yeah neatly why
tell me what made you join the Academy
because here's the thing
I can I'd say let's talk about the
Academy so the Academy I used to run
crash courses but yeah hmm when you came
to the first crash course it was a
training Kings
tell me about that so traded Kings there
was a handful of us there must have been
about eight of us in a room that's
including you and although me and you in
a room he feels like there's a hundred
exactly and and we literally was sort of
circling around you look laptop came up
to Birmingham and you were really
amazing like you know you I didn't know
it was your first I mean I never knew
because you were really confident and
obviously that's because you was already
financially free so it was easy for you
to teach something that wasn't a
millionaire he wasn't a millionaire and
I said I said that at the time yeah like
I wasn't and my whole message back then
was financial financial freedom make a
couple grand on but what's incredible
about you is that you actually you don't
keep anything too
yourself you just kind of like let
everyone know how you do it yeah and you
taught us step by step how we can
actually do it now if we want to take
those skills and actually do it that's
up to us but you gave us those skills
and you're still doing it now which is
amazing but you know what though when I
run the crash course there was no
advanced training there was no like
Academy yeah or three day or five day
perhaps solutely I'm just the crash
course definitely definitely but it
definitely it was elite she was just a
crash how much to favor the crash course
I think was about 250 250 pounds yeah
and now it's free would you look at that
oh yeah and you won the competition and
what did you money for it I did yeah you
owe me you owe me for that is now at the
crash Kaufmann someone's a good deal I
give them money for but but it's just
crazy man so what have you learned in
actually doing all of this stuff in
running a business you have staff and
stuff presumably how many staff do you
have I have I would say about 20 soft
about 20 staff yeah security and I knew
as young as well yeah yeah yes I am 131
yeah so you're 31 you've got 20 members
of staff approximately yeah you you and
your partner returning over a million
pounds EMU Club you got rent to rent I
know as well you've done within property
you've got help your friends and you've
done you've done deals where you friends
that didn't have money through up their
houses I would say look I'll invest in
you I want to double my money
so I had a friend who just got a new
flat and she had a two-bedroom and she
wasn't able to do it up so I said to her
look I'll do it up but I want to double
my money
and she was happy with that so I was
able to rent out one of her rooms and
get that money back over a period of
time so I've always I've always done
I've always dabbled in in property all
the way up until I bought it in 2018 but
bought my house in 2018 but what really
taught me because speaking something I'm
very passionate about as well as as you
know what really taught me how to speak
was training my staff I would always
train my staff and tell them the story
of my success I started as a glass
collector I worked as a waitress I then
was a head waitress and a manager and
the general
I have my own club you know my own
late-night bar and and that inspires
them to work hard because it's not what
you do it's how you do it yeah and it's
the spirit of what you do it so true you
know so also as well the thing that just
freaks me out is because if are
successful you are now and in your mind
I get this I was just a meeting right
now it's almost like you must be
pinching yourself you must be so proud
of yourself and it's like I am yes
because I know of where I want to get
yeah I don't know that you're and one of
the hungriest people I know that we
depend a lot of time together recently
so so you're not just patting yourself
on the back at all say I have done well
you're saying no no no I'm just getting
started
the funny thing is when I felt pregnant
last year everyone was saying you know
you're in a good position now you know
you can sit back because you've trained
your staff you know you can sit back and
kind of like you know go in once in a
while to kind of retain train them you
know just relax and enjoy the fruits of
your labor but after having once I was
pregnant I thought if God forbid
anything happened to my partner right
now how are we going to survive you know
so even though it's sounds great and
it's very romantic you know having your
own business it's still I'm looking for
that passive income for that cash flow
so you want massive income but also
passive you were living in like a
council flat yeah I moved out when I was
16 years old what's your story like tell
me about how you grew up and where did
what's your background
I mean um background I mean my mom my
mum's my grandparents were English my
mom was adopted so my grandpa's were
English and we saw herself as
middle-class we traveled a lot
throughout Africa I've been to over 10
countries in Africa I've been zv1
victory fraud for me so but yeah we
traveled to many different African
countries and then we came to the UK
when I was about eight and yeah but we
just you know went to school and what
and stuff but when I was 16 I decided to
move out living with my brothers and my
sister and it was really crowded and I
just wanted to move out so I actually
was in hostels for years I moved to like
seven different hostels all around
London and
yeah when I was 18 I got a council flat
and it was and it wasn't anything
special and if he looked at it you'll
bring I'm not but ya got it given from
the council I was on benefits at the
time so you and Bennett I was on
benefits yeah I was on benefits for a
long time and I said to my mom when I
was a teen mom gonna buy this house 10
years later I did and it was a lovely
little studio apartment and yeah I just
fell in love with their aloneness I do
thought I owned it yeah you still own it
so so from from benefits yeah to be may
you be the owner of it absolutely
I said no no I I'm not allowed to rent
it out okay so you told me you got it
yeah yeah but I've just gotten planning
permission to develop it so I will
eventually you know once I can also buy
to let mortgage I was going to say
because I looked into this hole right to
acquire what am i yeah and there's no
rules that you can't rent it out and I
was gonna ask you about that you can
rent it but what you can't do is you
can't sell it and problem you can Senate
you can't sell it and you'd have to tell
your bank that you rented it out so yeah
very true absolutely yeah yes cool okay
yeah so what are the big learning points
then because I know you learned a lot on
the crash course what and and and and
you know I loved having you on the day
there as well I'm saying honesty and I
actually wanted to talk about it because
the crash course to the crash course you
know everyone goes into what I came into
the crash course like okay you know I'm
coming to listen and you know obviously
the kind of mindset of you know I'm not
gonna buy anything you know and i sat
there and i list you wanna bet sorry
are you one about the recent crash
course or the one from six years ago no
the resync oh the recent the recent
crappy gets that in a minute cause I
think I want to know why you came back
and I want to get know why I came back
okay [ __ ] minutes in a minute but I
want to first talk about the first crash
course okay yeah and then I want to go
through the learnings over the last six
years
yeah and then we
logic always yes that's fine let's move
everywhere that's fine okay was though
the first crash course let's get the
story so what happened on the first
crash course and what were the learning
points or what kind of happened so you
would teach in financial freedom so you
were teaching a rental ramp was one of
the bigger strategies that you were
teaching at that time the biggest one
that I took away yeah and you would just
sort of let people know that don't look
at houses romantically and think oh this
is what I want to buy and because it's
got a beautiful garden a great front
garden and all these wonderful trimmings
you were showing me these really
bog-standard like properties up north
that you know no one's really gonna
desire and you were telling me look at
that 60 K you just have to put 10% 20%
down they'd sent down and and you made
it possible yes that's what you did for
me you made it possible for me to be in
that position yeah you know because a
lot of other places that I went to after
that which she told me to go to there
were so many people in so many different
sits so many different you know six with
so many different success stories yeah
but you made it possible you made me
feel like comfortable with the prospects
of being a property owner okay so that's
the first class course yeah there six
years
what were the key learning points over
those six years what are the three
things that we're that you really learn
from what would you advise your six year
younger self right now just fresh out of
the crash course yeah knowing what you
know now know oh my god just go for it
just go for it it's possible it's
absolutely possible I mean educate
yourself you know that's what I would
have told myself I would have told
myself to really educate myself you know
and really learn you know have that full
confidence through the knowledge to
actually make it happen what have I
learnt over the last six years would be
I've learnt that it's so much I've done
so much insurance raised finance
commercial yeah I mean it's all it's all
based on confidence and it's all based
on on really making that plan to
actually make it happen and I feel like
entrepreneurism is like jumping off of a
if without a parachute figuring in how
to land you know what I mean it's almost
like you just got to go for it you just
got a do it we're just going to act upon
it yeah okay biggest tips around
networking because that I told you man
yeah I didn't have any advanced training
no I said you go to pay yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah which you did really well so
give me top tips on networking just get
out there just talk to people just be
open and to take notes
you know like taking notes really helped
me going back and reading those notes
really helped me building rapport with
people in the industry you know there's
lots of people in or you could just meet
your whole power team for networking so
it's just great to just immerse yourself
in like-minded people because you are
the company raising finance to give you
tips around that you've done that very
successfully basically bouncing cash do
you know what racing finance is it you
just go for it like whether you go into
a restaurant whether you're going to a
nightclub whether you're going to a
network and ever just go for us people
speak to people and what is really
taught me is how to sell I think that's
the biggest lesson because you need to
sell yourself you need to sell your idea
you know what I mean and to raise
finance you have to paint a vision to
people that will enable them to see what
it is that you're saying even though
it's not that yeah I had to take people
into a venue had no bar that was dusty
that was a shell and convince people
that 300 people are going to walk
through this door and there's gonna be a
bar there and tables there this is the
VIP and these all the wonderful amazing
things and I had to convince them they
had to see it and live it and feel it
and once they did they were they they
typed into and they you know before they
before they had to see you have to see
absolutely which is face face is seeing
fans they are not there yet yeah
absolutely absolutely okay so that's a
mate you're one of the most powerful
women I know that oh wow
syria's know what
such a powerful strong confident person
a lot of what you've been talking about
is confidence yeah of course you've got
the skills you can of course you went
network and you met a lot of people
where does that confidence come from my
goodness I honestly is something that
I've had to really life really froze
that use so many different challenges
you know it really does and you have to
be able to truly believe that what
you're doing is the right thing and you
have to not care what other people think
I think that's the biggest thing I'd
want a lot of women out there to know is
to not care what people think especially
in this time when we really care about
the likes and all the things that people
say on social media wherever it may be
what builds confidences is not caring
what other people think about you and
just being yourself yes tell me about
how you got the rent to rent through my
mom so what a mouth you know she spoke
to a friend she's a psychiatric nurse
she deals with adolescents and so she
works with a lot of other nurses and one
of the ladies but it seems like I'm
moving away and I really need someone to
manage my house I'm having issues with
with just managing my house my mom was
like my sister my daughter sorry my
daughter is into property because I
always talk about me being into property
yeah she just hooked me up and I got the
the flat and invested a little bit doing
it up and I just I rented it out within
a day a day three how much do you pay
1200 1200 and you rent out for how much
2200 2200 so there we go there's it up
and you manage it yourself yeah so it's
just straightforward
yes simple and and does why is she happy
to take such a hit is it the peace of
mind or what is it peace of mind yeah so
she's like look man you make your
thoughts and and she's been in a
situation where she's having to pay out
when she's doing other things and
generally and she's not in the country
so for her it's just important for her
to at least cover her own how much time
do you spend a week or a month managing
that like I said it took me a day to
rent out 30 minutes it took me to do
free rooms you know and
that's it so it's pretty easy I just
received the money every month so that
is the perfect read to remember this
love is lovely so you had your kid mmm
c-section crazy crazy what happened and
what made you then come back to the
crash course so when I was pregnant I
was obviously I was really big and
everyone sort of talk and relax so I
spent like nine months just like
chilling out and then I started to watch
homes under the hammer I'm randomly
instead of recording and just watching
it and then gave birth had my way
enjoyed you know the first couple of
months of motherhood it was really
beautiful really romantic and you know
just took it all in and then it got to
like the third month that I might okay
what what else am I supposed to do and
then you know as a woman you know women
most of us all a lot of us our bodies do
change you know I was really small
before I had my son I was modeling on
social media and I was very confident in
my the way I looked after having a baby
I just kind of felt like I wasn't myself
so I felt like what it did for me is it
took me away from the kind of
superficial part of my my personality
and made me focus on okay if I didn't
have you know if I didn't look the way
that I looked what do I have left and I
had my personality and my character so I
started building on that so I started to
buy the books do the research and and
then as soon as I saw that you know
YouTubed
property meaning you just came up
straight away and that just seeing you
where you are now and having been in
your crash course have been the first
person that was like the biggest wake-up
call for me you know because I've seen
you without you know what I mean and I
believed you then yes so to then see
where you've gone the amount of people
that are looking at your your your clips
and the successes that you're talking
about and how open and war you are and
all these different lessons that you've
learned over over the years I believed
you yeah so I bought books
I did the work I did the work at home
and and then it was actually just off to
Christmas we were all out my brother's
house meshach who you know yeah really
well and he was like look what's animals
doing and he put on your seven-day
financial free financially free in seven
days and and I was just yeah it just
pumped me because I was like yeah I
believe him of course you don't often
have to have any money if you've got no
knowledge you can make it happen
so I was like I'm gonna do that and then
I saw your crash course and I was like
right let me just start it now before
the year begins and and yeah and I
wasn't even there at the crash course he
wasn't
but it does say online that you might
not be there I was like oh I really want
to see him although ironically I did I
was there I did make an appearance in
the evening but I know you didn't get
back maybe I did show me you didn't even
see me at the crash course what was it
like as you journey with him what was it
like it was it was such a beautiful
experience for me because I walked in
and I walked through the room and you
know it a thousand people in the room
you know we knew there were those eight
I'm right there where there's eight and
and fast forward six years and there's a
thousand people in the room and the the
Once Upon a Time little laptop is now a
massive screen on TV with somebody else
like showing everyone how to do how to
source these properties and I'm looking
around the room and I'm like oh my god
you know oh my goodness and you didn't
need to be there because I already knew
your lessons with that yeah so I didn't
feel like I needed you to to be there I
felt like I I would love to have seen
you at that time but I felt just I could
see the testimonies of the people on
stage and I could see that the people
that were teaching and they were
phenomenal teachers and you know that
that really inspired me and I was just
sort of walking around everyone like I
used to be here when there was eight of
us and you know I've almost like what no
way and I'm like yeah I guess be eight
of us back in the day look how big it's
got but the real moment for me was what
made me want to take that next step was
when when
I love him so much
what about trainers he's incredible
anandhi incredible just amazing he's
like he talks like it's butter you know
everything's just so just smooth with
him he was on stage and he said you know
does anyone know what a red diamond
moment is and he explained that a red
diamond moment is like you know the
first day that you live you only have
two days that are most important in your
life the day that you're born and the
day that you find out what you need what
you want in life and and he said he
picked up one of the Academy papers and
was like this is your red diamond moment
and honestly it was like I couldn't deny
I couldn't turn away I couldn't pretend
I couldn't say oh no let me know I I had
to stand up and take that academy piece
of paper and I wrote on it and I said
I'm gonna rock your world I'd love you
to find it cuz actually she said that on
your paper I said I'm gonna rock your
world fine and it just felt right I just
felt I just felt bigger yeah you know I
thought like I was growing and you
joined the Academy I did and you started
how's it been so far so after we all
joined and got a little badges yellow
but the yellow badge of honor and we all
went up to have a glass of Prosecco or
champagne and this is on the crash
course and there was only a handful of
us out of all those thousands of people
is only like oh no like 15 of us in the
room out of a thousand people and that
may be like five of us that actually did
wear on the Academy itself and on came
in and we all cheers and all the other
speakers came in as well and I heard the
aeroplanes mics off taken off because we
were in Heathrow and we all sort of
cheers and I just felt so like this is
the family this is where I'm supposed to
be and then yeah and then obviously I
went to South Africa I let benaiah
who I was who signed me up that I'm
going stuff half-a-crown I won't be able
to start until I get back
he was totally fine with that and then I
messaged you yeah that day you got back
from South Africa my house yes so I
landed at 4:30 in the morning a.m. I
went home got dressed made as soon and
drove up to your house which was
incredible beautiful house and then
Amanda who's just stunning and just
amazing she's a lovely lovely woman and
your kids which was beautiful I came in
Messiah he was so welcoming I was able
to bring my son which was beautiful
and we all sat around the table and I
had dinner and a chat and yeah it was
then he went to the business of property
investing which is one of the Academy
training programs yes so you actually
advised me I was like oh I'm gonna take
my time with it like you know I want to
make sure that I'd get the information
in like why I just get it done like
straightaway so say yeah okay I will so
I immediately came to to the next
available crash course class the
business of property investor and it
Academy sir Academy class the business
yes actually and it was amazing it was
amazing and the reason why it was
amazing is because everyone that was
there was like it leveled up yeah so
everyone was there was just as
enthusiastic as I was yeah so everyone
was willing to jump up and have a good
time everyone wanted to learn everyone
wanted to just take it and take in all
the information and honestly it was for
me and I don't even mean to sound too
deep but I kind of felt like it was
spiritual like I felt like I just kind
of entered into a different a different
realm you know I was able to be myself
get information and learn things and do
them because it wasn't me seeking this
perfection of waiting it was as they as
you guys say done is the new perfect do
it and just do it don't worry about it
not being perfect just get it done and
that just made me feel alive
it did and you know one of the people on
the Academy just the best kind of people
I mean I've made so many friends I love
running these training programs and be
part of it because everyone there as you
said they all want
well yeah they all support each other
yeah a lot of them even though some of
them a lot of them we know a lot of them
are very successfully promise you making
very good money being in that
environment is more powerful than trying
to drum up well power yourself
absolutely absolutely 100% and you I
mean I've connected with like maybe 15
20 people we've just been messaging each
other and we're gonna work together and
stuff just off the back of the course
but also we get to have like meet ups
and things like that which again kind of
irons us I'm you know iron sharpens iron
kind of thing but really yeah it just
it's just beautiful honestly he was
I just kept understands and I was like
okay I'm just gonna keep yeah standing
up as much as I can and just get
involved because asking questions plow
self out there myself out there and a
lot of people you know like a lady came
to me afterwards and we exchanged
numbers right after the call she came
and sat down she said to me you know I'm
28 years old I've got five you know
properties to rent to rent but I really
want to learn confidence and I said how
come you're so confident and I was able
to teach her that off the back of that
so it's like yeah it's just just be just
be yourself and also joint venture
galore because everyone's doing
businesses
yeah joint venture it that's awesome so
what's next what can we expect from you
over the next year oh my goodness I mean
I have I have such big dreams you know I
have such big dreams there's so much of
its manifested you know I put I put
speaking on stage on my mood board on my
phone it manifested within a month you
know and I've got other things I've got
I want to do you know but by a handful
of properties I want to get into the
lease option agreement so want to get
more into rents you know I'd love to
speak on your stage you know I think I
think that's a given
I just would love to you know that is
something that I would love to do you
know and yeah it makes me feel amazing
it does if there's a real satisfaction
in inspiring other people I know you've
got a real heart to have a lot women
especially yes yes yes women just you
know my god the amount of days that I
sat at home you know wishing and hoping
and dreaming and I'm hoping and you know
and honestly you need to put yourself
out there and it really will manifest
for you
yeah it really well leaving yourself so
what would be your
Marnell pieces pieces of advice words of
wisdom words of encouragement 21
watching this who's maybe they've never
been to the crash course or maybe yeah
what would you say I would say just if
you but it's all about believe in
yourself and I would advise everybody
you know whether you go is the crash
course whether you go into the Academy
definitely make sure you buy the books
you know I've bought all some of these
books you know I've made sure that I've
given myself the best chance to succeed
so always give yourself the best chance
and that will give you the confidence
when you're in the crash course to then
eventually go to the Academy because you
think I already know a lot so I can now
go to that next step and that next level
and just be open and don't worry about
what people think and it might seem you
know like corny some time since someone
dance and jumping up and down it doesn't
matter like you're not gonna see half
the people again you know just just if
you really want something just really
really go for it and just be open it
just be yourself so that was it and one
thing I wanted to say whenever almost
are saying things about you is for me
what kept on coming to mine was setting
the captives free and cuz you were
talking about you really want to focus
on those that are working-class and
there are you know middle class and and
and and other people may be trying to
convince you otherwise
and honestly focusing on people like
myself or people like that the vast
majority of the world is the people to
focus on because those are the people
that need it you know what I mean and
that need to know how to get there I
have every reason not to be where I am
today I have every reason not to be
where I am today I'm a a council house
you know young woman that lived in West
London you know what I mean that lived
in a council house I have every reason
not to be in my position so but the
reason why I am in my position and why
I'm gonna go further is because I'm
surrounding myself with the right people
you know what I mean surrounding myself
with the people that I want to be like
and that's what the Academy brings
that's what the crash course currents it
gives you the ability to be around the
people that you want to be like that's
awesome
Hey
thank you for just being an amazing
person thank you for coming on thank you
for joining the Academy and believing in
us as well as limited in yourself and
used awesome so will no not see you
again on this channel no doubt people
come to the crash course may even hear
you on stage
okay thanks so much respect or - love
[Music]